when it comes to the climate and the
environment and energy i know what i do
not believe
i do not believe all of the
liberal technocrats who are trying to
upend my way of life and take away all
of my energy and tell me that the sun
monster is going to kill us in 10 years
i don't believe that i don't have any
respect for that point of view i'm no
expert but i still think it's more than
likely a bunch of bunk the harder
question is
what do we believe and what do we do
about it especially now with energy
prices soaring up to decades-long highs
here to help me make sense of it is alex
epstein the author of the new book
fossil future why global human
flourishing requires more oil coal and
natural gas
not less alex thank you for coming on
the show awesome to be honest as i told
you before i've never seen my book in
person before so i got it before you
didn't expect i just had a printed
version and it's like oh my god that's
so cool only the best for our guests we
even give you your own book so
alex yeah
i know that the alarmists
are full of it i just know i am not a
trained
ecologist or climatologist i just i just
know it i'm curious how you know because
i think there are a lot of signs that
anyone can pick up even if you're not
trained so i'm curious what you've seen
well so here's one reason that i'm
skeptical of it is because a lot of
their predictions for the past 50 years
haven't come true yes so
i'm a new yorker it's not underwater i
go to florida a lot we're okay we're not
swimming around in miami right so
that would be part of it
number two i am always skeptical of any
apocalyptic claim because historically
speaking
they don't come true
and certainly not when people eventually
one of them will come true but they
don't usually happen on people's
timetables
and three i'm very skeptical of
technocrats
who believe that the entire universe is
within their power to manipulate and
engineer and transform and their their
prideful belief in that also usually
does not come true so that is my gut
level reaction as to why i don't think
we're all going to be dead in nine years
from
the sun or whatever yeah i mean i think
those are two key elements right the
what i call the catastrophizing so the
predicting these catastrophes that not
only don't happen but in general life
has gotten much better and you're right
about the 50-year timetable we've had
these catastrophe predictions for 50
years and life has gotten dramatically
better i mean i was born in 1980 we had
four out of 10 people living on less
than two dollars a day now it's less
than one in ten so there's been this
unbelievable improvement in human life
this alleviation of poverty and and so
it's the opposite of the catastrophe
they were one not just wrong but 180
degrees wrong even on an issue
related to but distinct from the climate
issue
on the so-called population bomb yes 50
years ago almost exactly we were told
within 10 years there would be mass
famine that was inevitable now or 50
years later
the world population doubled and
malnutritions at an all-time low yes and
so with this catastrophizing in fossil
fuels i talk about four specific
instances so you have catastrophic
resource depletion catastrophic
pollution which means not just some air
quality issues but that literally won't
be able to breathe you know the sunlight
will be blocked these were real
predictions in the 70s then catastrophic
global cooling that's three and then
catastrophic global warming and all four
have come false even though we've had
warming it has not been catastrophic
actually as i point out the rate of
death from climate-related disasters
which is the important thing and telling
us how safe we are from climate that's
gone down by 98
in the last hundred years so we're
actually 50 times safer from
climate-related disaster so there's
something very wrong and i think one
thing to amplify your point is there's
no apology there's not an
acknowledgement hey guys we totally
screwed it up here's why and here's why
you should trust us in fact they act
like they've been vindicated like say
paul ehrlich who's been around for over
50 years he is still a leading what i
call a designated expert in the society
right he has tons of credibility just
two years ago people were publishing far
and wide a uh a statement that he was
one of the big signees on like how can
you be 180 degrees wrong for 50 years
and you're an authority so that shows
there's something corrupt and
unscientific about this movement it's
not self-correcting it's the opposite it
gets it totally wrong and it claims
validation and is totally unapologetic
now you mentioned that there has been
some warming
so this raises a few more questions
beyond just what i don't believe namely
the lab coat geniuses who are sitting at
the u.n
so what what do i believe
is global warming real
what is it
does it matter
and what should the effect of that be on
our energy policy
i think those are good ways to think
about it i think about it a little bit
differently because i think even
starting with global warming and making
that the center is an error because the
cause of global warming is basically our
greenhouse gas emissions or at least
that's a cause and i believe it's a
significant cause of what so far is a
very small amount of warming i should
say but it's important that it comes
from the burning of fossil fuels which
provide eighty percent of the energy
that the world uses to live at an
unprecedented level and by the way the
world drastically needs more energy so
one stat i like is that we have three
billion people who use less electricity
each than one of our refrigerators so
the world is drastically underpowered
and fossil fuels are by far the dominant
source of energy for reasons we get into
that's not just a coincidence or a
conspiracy there are certain things
they're uniquely good at and so when
we're looking at co2 we need to look at
it as a side effect of fossil fuels we
need to look at the benefits and the
side effects carefully just like you
would a prescription drug and this is
for me what led me to be suspicious
above all the catastrophizing was one
thing but the other thing was the
benefit denial denying the benefits so
i'll give you an example that's very
relevant right now one of the leading
thinkers on this issue is a guy named
michael mann so he's a famous guy who
writes for the washington post he's been
at penn state and very prominent etc
he's considered oh we should listen to
this guy he's quote the scientists when
we're told listen to the scientists so
michael mann has a book called the mad
house effect that is trying to teach the
public about how to think about climate
and energy so he talks about agriculture
which is crucial because we all need to
eat as you mentioned we're better fed
than ever so he talks about well warming
is going to have these challenges to
agriculture and that's fine right that's
like looking at the side effects of a
prescription drug but in that whole book
guess how many times he mentions the
benefits of fossil fuels which power
virtually every piece of farm equipment
and make all of our fertilizer guess how
many times i'm going to guess not very
many zero there's not you search
fertilizer none of it but but just step
back and think how crazy this is it is
exactly like the polio vaccine comes out
and you only talk about the side effects
and you don't mention oh by the way it
stops polio this stops hunger fossil
fuels have stopped hunger and michael
mann our designated expert cannot talk
about one benefit so he is a fossil fuel
benefit denier and anyone who does not
acknowledge the incredible benefits of
fossil fuels is either ignorant or we
might get into this they have a
different definition of benefit than we
do a definition that is anti-human
because as you're saying
i think you're very right about this i
mean we're right now in a debate over
the very nature of life in our uh united
states political climate over roe versus
wade although you and i would have
differences on that one so that'll be
that but that's not my focus here we
regardless of of one's views on abortion
though
the the relevant aspect is that
the frame
sets the entire debate so yes i believe
that uh you know if we're talking about
abortion i think more babies
and less abortion is a benefit uh some
people say no more individual autonomy
even if it means fewer babies is a
benefit so we're both speaking in terms
of benefits we just we're just not
agreeing on what is conducive to human
flourishing and so you're saying in this
very different arena that in
it when we're talking about energy and
and environment you need to define what
a benefit is yeah but i think
because you mentioned conducive to human
flourishing differences but so a
difference within what is conducive to
human flourishing is different from a
difference between you care about human
flourishing and you don't so take the
clearest cut example i think is the
animal rights movement animal rights
leaders know that animal testing for
medical research is crucial to human
flourishing it's provided huge benefits
and yet many of them are against it why
why do they ignore the huge benefits of
animal testing for medical research to
human beings and why are they so focused
on the alleged negatives it's because
their their goal and their standard is
animal rights they believe that the goal
is to not impact animals and so that
goal defines what a benefit is so when
they see a bunch of people dying for
lack of medical research that's good
because we didn't harm those animals and
so what i believe is the root cause of
the modern anti-fossil fuel movement
this is a controversial claim but i
think it is is the belief that human
impact on nature is evil and our goal
should be to eliminate it so that's what
i think drives the leaders like paul
ehrlich why is he so wrong and why
doesn't he care because really he thinks
he's right because he thinks the evil is
not harming humans it's impacting nature
and so he looks at the last 50 years and
he says hey guess what we've impacted
nature a lot and you and i say that's
great because human life is so good
right we have so much more food or more
security he's like no
impacting nature is evil so by his by
that standard it hasn't been a benefit
billions more people flourishing is a
negative to him
so that that's that's a truly anti-human
perspective that i think many people
have picked up in a diluted and
disguised form so then how should we
think about it because i'm not just some
uh
you know rah-rah industrialists knock
down all the trees and build a bunch of
right
power plants or something i i want to be
a good steward of nature i want
beautiful nature outside that i can
enjoy uh but i'm i'm also not going to
starve a country so that the delta smelt
can have a better time either what what
should our our framework be this this is
a beautiful question actually the first
section of fossil future is called
framework so i think it's all about what
is the framework we use to think about
our relationship to our environment so
you can call this our environmental
framework our environmental philosophy
and you mentioned that you want to enjoy
nature and you also don't want people to
die and so that's consistent with what i
think the environmental goal should be
which is to advance human flourishing so
to advance human flourishing around the
world and that includes the ability to
enjoy nature but also the ability to eat
which comes before that to be safe from
nature all sorts of other things
many people draw a distinction between
like the environment which they think of
as non-human nature and then us which
they think of as unnatural and i don't
think of it that way i think of it as
all nature
and i think we're the best part of
nature and we should focus on ourselves
but for example like i think a a
skyscraper is a great addition to our
environment and i think a waterfall is a
great part of our environment so when i
look at the world i look at it all from
a human flourishing perspective i don't
have a bias against things we've created
some things we've created are amazing
most are good some are bad and some
things in nature are good and some are
bad like the malarial mosquito i want to
get rid of that thing my dog i want to
give him an artificially good chance at
life the polar bear i love it it's
beautiful but i want to section it off
so that it doesn't kill us so the key is
to think of it as our environmental goal
is to advance human flourishing on earth
and the opposite environmental goal is
to eliminate human impact on earth and
you can really divide people by at least
the leaders by is your goal to advance
human flourishing on earth or to
eliminate human impact on earth and they
are not compatible goals sometimes right
advancing human flourishing you don't
impact something because it's beautiful
like a piece of nature but you impact
nature a lot to have the wealth to get
there to have the transportation to get
there so it's all about what advances
human flourishing it's not about do you
impact things or not that's just immunes
to an end right okay so that that makes
perfect sense to me
but why do we need fossil fuels to do it
to take the side of the less hysterical
and extremist
libs here why can't we just move to
solar or wind or
nuclear well usually they don't mention
new facts
yes but that's notable or hydro either
so so why
well please talk about those as well but
then specifically why fossil fuels so
but i think it is it is notable in
revealing of the motives of the other
side that the most plausible
alternatives to fossil fuels nuclear and
hydro they are the biggest opponents of
and in particular i mean we just had
joe biden has an appointee to what's
called the nuclear regulatory commission
which is really the nuclear destruction
commission in its 40 47 year existence
it has not approved one plant from
beginning to end so it's essentially
stopped the nuclear industry made it
prohibitively expensive and the green
movement is the leader of this so the
same people who claim to care so much
about co2 emissions are also the biggest
opponents of nuclear which doesn't emit
co2 and it's the only alternative with a
track record of being relatively low
cost that can theoretically scale around
the world hydro is great it can be low
cost but it can't scale everywhere
because it depends on certain topography
like you can't use it in really flat
places and that kind of thing so they're
so against nuclear also against hydro
and so this confirms my idea that it's
really all about human impact is evil
it's not about
so much fear of co2 but just the belief
that we shouldn't split the atom it's
unnatural we shouldn't create a new type
of waste even though that waste is
pretty benign it's pretty easy to deal
with so it's really a hostility toward
human impact so when we see that they're
insisting on solar and wind above all
things that should have a a religious
quality like there's some reason why
they want this and and the reason is
pretty clear they consider those natural
right they think of it as oh we're
living they're renewable we're living in
harmony with the sun whereas from human
flourishing perspective renewable is not
a real word you don't care about that
you just care about what's
cost-effective and that's part of a
long-term strategy and you're okay with
using one thing one 500 year period and
one thing one five thousand year period
right so it's important that it has this
religious quality that's saying like but
this this primitive like natural is the
goal
um so when you when you look at it that
way i think it's another cause for
suspicion that it's actually true that
we can rapidly replace fossil fuels
which mind you provide eighty percent of
the world's energy today and growing
with solar and wind which provide only
electricity which is twenty percent of
the world's energy and they provide
three percent of the world's overall
energy almost only in places where they
are highly subsidized mandated or
otherwise preferred by government
and always dependent on a controllable
reliable source of energy on a grid like
uh like fossil fuels nuclear or hydra so
if you just think of it as fossil fuels
provide 80 of the world's energy in an
energy-hungry world and people are
claiming in the next 28 years we can
rapidly eliminate fossil fuels and
replace them with solar and wind that
are complete parasites right now that
depend on government and they're going
to provide all the world's energy not
just for the people who have it today
but for the billions more like that
should seem insane and in particular
this i would argue two years ago when i
was writing this book that was insane
now it should seem totally insane
because we have a little place called
europe and what did europe do they said
oh well we can replace fossil fuels a
solar wind will work great so what do
they do they you know basically pay
china mostly for a bunch of solar panels
and wind turbines and they shut down
fossil fuel production they basically
ban fracking the greatest energy
technology of our generation they don't
care at all about imports from free
countries because what fossil fuels are
going to take care of them then what
happened solar and wind are unreliable
they depend on reliable energy in
particular natural gas which can cycle
up and down to to deal with their
unreliability and where does their
natural cast come from not from them
because they didn't think they needed it
it comes from russia
and because of that so they're super
insecure but also because many others
around the world have restricted the
investment in fossil fuels the
production and the transport we have a
general supply shortage so right now the
world is desperately short of fossil
fuels and joe biden is begging every
dictator he can find to get them and he
also now has the gall to claim that he
was never against fossil fuels and he's
done nothing to restrict them so
what this is showing is this idea that
we can rapidly replace fossil fuels with
solar wind is just as implausible it's
just as impossible as you would guess
from this idea oh yeah energy hungry
world 80 fossil fuels we'll get rid of
all the fossil fuels and just solar and
wind will do it that never made any
sense and it's obviously wrong but biden
seems to have taken the opposite
conclusion from this which is he says
look at this war in europe look at
europe's dependency and our dependency
on russian oil and gas because i shut
down american production i wouldn't
expand american production
regardless of what he actually did he
says this is the proof that we need to
move away from oil and gas this is just
dirty rotten dinosaur juice it's going
to run out and and the only way to into
the future not only to power our country
but to avoid war with a major power is
to get off of oil entirely
right so he's sort of playing it two
ways already saying okay yeah in the
short term it's like for a few more
years i admit we need fossil fuels right
but then of course the long-term thing
is this thing that's been it's kind of
like the catastrophist like they were
always wrong about the present but
they're always they were always just
premature
like oh we we were right but it's just
been delayed how far we're right and so
i always try to find things that are
anyone can know for certain that totally
contradict the alleged expert narrative
to show that there's something wrong
with the method of thinking of the
expert narrative so in this case what is
the obvious thing of saying solar and
wind are going to provide us amazing
energy security besides the fact that
they're unreliable and they depend on
reliable energy they all are controlled
by china so russia's involvement in oil
and gas particularly vis-a-vis the us is
nothing compared to china's complete
control of the supply chain of solar and
wind in particular not just the mining
of minerals but the processing of key
elements they totally control that they
can cut that off on a whim so
the idea of of putting this as this is
security to depend on solar wind like if
solar and when we're way cheaper we'd
have a real security concern because we
say well they're cheaper but we depend
on china but here they're not cheaper
they can't replace fossil fuels at all
because they're unreliable and batteries
are nowhere near the scale to support
them in any kind of rube goldberg scheme
people can imagine so they're more
expensive they're they're not reliable
and they come from the most unstable
source imaginable so this is not a
again the goal is not seriously thinking
about what will advance human
flourishing it's just this this desire
to eliminate our impact at all costs and
not that biden is a deeply anti-human
himself but he's following well he's
following this dogma of we should
eliminate our impact and in particular
above all we need to eliminate our co2
emissions look at how dominant this has
become
every big corporation now says their
number one goal is to eliminate co2
emissions become net zero right that's
become the literally the number one
moral goal in the world
is to eliminate co2 emissions and yet as
i indicated before like the most
important thing we're far safer from
climate than we used to be and a big
reason is fossil fuel energy because
fossil fuels allow us to deal with heat
right by making it cool they allow us to
deal with the cold which is a far bigger
threat by making it warm but even things
like drought relief drought used to be a
huge killer the drought-related death
rate has gone down by over 99 because we
have things like modern irrigation
powered by fossil fuels
modern drought relief convoys powered by
fossil fuels so fossil fuels have taken
a naturally dangerous climate and made
it unnaturally safe
and yet why don't people talk about
those benefits they're only concerned
about co2 which is a warming gas and a
green and gas that has made it you know
one degree warmer in the last 170 years
in a world where more people die of cold
than of heat there's like no reason at
all to be catastrophic about climate
given that we're so much safer from it
because of fossil fuels and given that
the alleged danger involves warming
which is something that we generally
want as well as greening so there's no
pro-human explanation for saying this is
a catastrophe but if you view impact on
nature as a catastrophe then it's a
catastrophe it's like by just by
definition exactly by definition it's a
catastrophe because it's a lot of impact
and our impact is evil so i think that's
what's driving the world right now the
belief not that
not that co2 emissions are really going
to be terrible for us but that they're
intrinsically terrible because they are
from us right right because because they
have changed anything about this the
natural scheme of the world yes so but
now
realize natural excludes humans right
it's not about loving nature it's about
hating humans because we are singled out
our impact is bad
all other beavers impact is great birds
so i call this human racism because it's
the idea that everything the human race
does yeah against us is bad and
everything everything else inanimate or
animate does is good so again i want to
dissociate this perspective from like
love of the wilderness no it's hatred of
the human part of nature now is there
anything that we have to do
to deal with carbon so we've said okay
we believe maybe there's some degree of
warming and we've uh but look at all
these immense benefits we don't want to
deny these benefits but there is still
then this question of a lot more carbon
being released is there anything we have
to do about it or it's just not a big
deal move on in the immediate term we
need to release more carbon no i mean
very seriously i mean the subtitle is
why global human flourishing requires
more oil coal and natural gas a lot less
so the
but that's the reason for that is the
imperative is the world needs far more
energy to give another stat we have five
billion people right now living on less
than ten dollars a day
and energy is crucial to getting out of
that because without energy human beings
are just our physically weak selves and
we're very unproductive living on a
planet that is naturally deficient it
doesn't have very much stuff and it's
very dangerous so to live in an abundant
and safe world you need machines to
radically improve your productive
ability that's just a fact of human
nature and for machines you need machine
food which is energy and that needs to
be low cost and reliable otherwise you
can't afford it so it's just a basic
fact that those five billion people need
far more energy and that fossil fuels
are uniquely cost effective in that they
can provide low-cost reliable energy for
every type of machine including things
like cargo ships and planes that nothing
else can come close to competing with
right now and they can do it on a scale
of billions of people in thousands of
places i do think nuclear is a very
promising alternative but it's been
basically criminalized by the left so
it's declining in many places it's
become prohibitively expensive i am
maybe the world's biggest advocate in
terms of decriminalizing nuclear it's a
big life focus of mine but as a
practical matter nuclear is not going to
be widely available for many decades and
so really we need far more energy which
means we need far more fossil fuel and
as i've pointed out
fossil fuel use comes with an amazing
what i call climate mastery ability so
it allows us to take all forms of
climate danger whether natural which is
massive or man-made which so far is
pretty small and and make it far safer
so it allows us to neutralize drought
neutralize extreme heat so what's going
to happen is we're going to have a world
if people follow the fossil future right
we'll do it anyway to some extent but if
we do it to the extent that i think is
good far more people benefit we'll have
a world that's far more abundant far
safer far safer from climate because
people have this amazing climate mastery
ability and it will be a little bit
warmer and it'll be greener so it'll be
a little bit more of a tropical world
which by the way we are it's great i
love going to hawaii well but it's
terrific but it's it's notable it's not
if if we didn't have this bias against
human impact i believe we would probably
think that rising co2 was good on its
own i don't think it can be proven
either way because there's too much
uncertainty about how everything works
but there are huge benefits so i really
want to stress this that we should be
open to the possibility that co2 on its
own is a net benefit that is we would
wish now my case doesn't depend on that
even if it's a net harm the benefits of
the energy far outweigh it but when
we're looking at this
if we look at at co2 from a human
perspective we don't have this hatred of
it in this fear of it we just think yeah
okay the world will be more tropical to
some degree what do i want to do
am i going to like that am i going to
not like it uh what you know where do i
move it it's over a long period of time
now i do think that um when you're
talking like two generations from now
it's legitimate what is legitimate is we
would like the ability to control co2
and make it our choice so right now it
is a as a byproduct right it's a side
effect of the form of energy that we
need to be productive and to flourish it
would be good if we could just control
that either way and so that's one reason
i'm very in favor of alternatives the
main reason i'm in favor of alternatives
is i want something better than fossil
fuels eventually and i think nuclear has
the most potential because it's far more
concentrated which is a key attribute of
good energy so what we should be doing
at the same time is liberating
cost-effective alternatives uh that
includes natural gas which emits less
co2 than most fossil fuels but above all
nuclear but also things like what's
called deep geothermal going very deep
underground
and we have to liberate it from the same
movement that's against fossil fuels
because if you believe human impact is
evil are you going to allow people to
drill a couple miles under the earth for
deep geothermal are you going to allow
them to split the atom in new ways no so
what we need is a pro-human movement for
all for energy freedom for all forms of
energy it needs to be much more about
empowering the world and not at all
about eliminating our impact on the
world a pro-human movement which is not
necessarily anti-delta smelt but which
recognizes the delta smelt has its place
okay and we're here to be stewards of
nature and to to flourish and to grow
and uh and one way to do that
as you argue i think quite convincingly
is our fossil future why global human
flourishing requires more oil coal and
natural gas not less by alex epstein
alex thanks for coming in awesome thanks
great to meet you
[Music]
[Music]
you